oh hé d'accord euh hé
allons-nous aller de l'autre côté du
train et revenir
est les officiels d'accord d'accord
est
oui
une ligne ici euh
d'accord d'accord
alors
je lève ce cercle autour d'ici
oh
un cercle de plus s'il vous plaît
pouvons-nous à un certain stade venir  plus près et
faire un gros zoom sur le coton oui ouais
on aura ce plan large d'abord ouais bien
sûr d'accord
ça arrêtera un gâchis là
et si on pouvait se rapprocher et s'abaisser
étranger
euh
continuer à tourner en rond
oh hé
ben non tu ferais mieux  attends qu'ils
recommencent à travailler d'accord d'accord oh
merde
j'ai besoin de le couvrir
comme ça pouvons-nous être plus loin d'
eux et laura s'il vous plait
n'allez nulle part parce qu'il va y
avoir un
cercle étranger ici d'accord
j'en ai fini avec ce groupe  au
milieu pourrions-nous aller vers ce groupe au
bord du terrain étranger
étranger
d'accord euh
éventuellement mais continuez à tourner comme ça
pour le moment
ces deux-là sont très gentils
nous devrions les suivre vous savez
mais je pense que ça va ici
alors
d'accord
un  un peu, vous savez
un cercle de plus,
ils regardent toujours vers le haut de temps en temps,
en ce moment,
pouvons-nous
connaître un cadre où vous savez que nous
ne tournons pas autour d'eux où nous les
avons, vous savez, vous vous rapprochez d'
eux,
vous savez  nous devrons l'expliquer à la
batterie
où vous voulez voler
juste vous savez faire une ligne droite euh
une
place avant sans faire demi-tour d'accord
et venir vous savez faire un gros un
peu plus lent
j'utilise votre
centre de maintien
d'accord  Pouvons-nous recommencer s'il vous plaît
assurez-vous